só que o pessoal porque a atenção aqui
no começo no mercado uma bolada no olho
e porque eu tô aqui hoje com o meu
objetivo aqui hoje a você nem tem
sincero honesto você está
eu não tenho expectativa nenhuma de
funcionário em causa desse evento com
ninguém era disso que eu tô aqui hoje a
vender um produto fantástico produto
desde a infância já uso da gaza mas esse
produto é igual a transformar a vida de
vocês e de várias pessoas
por isso que a compartilhar com vocês
o senhor estava a receber
caminhando pela praia e era pai que
tinha uma uma certa extensão de areia e
uma horda grande coisa de três
quilômetros como fofinho e essa extensão
de areia nacional de tal caminho na vida
amanhã tinha 11 várias insistências do
lar na rio ea segunda do mar com um pano
sobre isso e não vai tentar destruir a
bola e só estava limpo a cada passo que
dava e osmar gustavo leão jogava no mar
mais um passo em que está fazendo ele
respondeu linha do mar vermelho
bastava humano
olha o tamanho da praia em milhares de
estrelas aqui
apesar do tempo que já acha que vai
conseguir com isso a diferença vai fazer
com o orgulho no show ela
a honda já tinha caminho e disse a ela
ali eu estou a diferença
e eu lembro também de sistemas uma
matéria onde tinha um homem de 35 40
anos que na cidade dele ele pegava todo
diante da tv e tinha uma hora do dia de
nossa cola e até a beira do rio que
cortava a cidade dele ele a matéria de
idade
ao longo da vida dele local dia e 365
ainda mais de 18 mil anos provavelmente
muito mais de 50 anos
o sistema passa do sabiá apis insetos
começar a notificar e até as de outras
árvores com base naquelas que ia mandar
uma missão é terminar o curso envie ao
vc é muito interessante é bem legal a
gente vai aprontar
talvez alguém você já sabe onde sob
total não é que tanto o senhor na
primeira história jornal as estrelinhas
andar com ele um homem pegar o lixo eo
o papa de um mês cada um de vocês aqui
um refugiado alguém estava a transformar
todos nós em com uma coisa talvez seja a
única coisa em comum mas todos os ovos
todo dia de cada vez menores em 24 anos
ninguém tem mais de quatro anos eu vi a
cor credo cultura está social o futebol
não voto nem 24 horas houve um todo dia
eu posso deixar de pensar em começar com
o que eu tenho pra onde eu tô uma
família que o 8 milhão há provavelmente
com teto uma um estudo com vencimento o
que eu estou fazendo o que eu posso
fazer para cada um de vocês têm alguma
coisa vocês já pensaram ter deixado de
lado
talvez seja telefones tom
seria impossível ter uma floresta
e então esse pensamento eu vou contar
pra vocês também uma outra história mas
eu quero falar pra vocês que hoje em dia
todo o projeto convida para participar a
fazer a mesma coisa que eu penso eu uso
a fazer o mesmo
alguém dê positivo esse projeto esse
trabalho vai transformar a vida de
alguém vai melhorar enquanto uma pessoa
que eu tenho que fazer meu tempo para
estudar nem energia para isso tudo
os recursos são a melhor no começo
simplesmente ouvir as coisas eu sentia
que tinha que fazer alguma coisa
e foi assim que eu comecei um dos
projetos mais chamado natal solidário
tem 42
mas eu comecei com aquilo
esse primeiro ano 1
edson falados e fizemos um dia de natal
pra te interessa se tinha ali e no ano
passado a natureza fundamental
só papai que os carentes da cidade de
lages
a gente conseguiu levar uma festa de
natal para mais de mil crianças são
bairros citar o homem é da cidade talvez
nem saiba que existe são áreas que ficam
35 quilômetros afastados do centro
sempre onde vive uma realidade todo
instante nós bacana também usava a jean
algum tempo com a família toda é que não
tem como se afastar do futebol
eu vejo lá até trazer pra cá e positiva
e um militar
em 2014 a gente fez primeira dentro de
nossa cidade lá
15 conheci uma mulher é uma pessoa
fantástica também já faziam um bom tempo
nas comunidades do ano e fez da união
são dois bairros e com a divisa entre
são josé e palhoça
quem não sabe minha maior favela de
santa catarina
no passado a gente conseguir fazer uma
festa de natal mas também mais três mil
crianças de 10 anos como papai noel tem
um lanche e refrigerante por mais que
seja público objeto de desejo você não
tem idéia de qual é a história de um de
três anos isso pra eles
qual é a ele estavam cantando estava
incomodada e dezembro verão calor pra
caramba
a criança estava sendo usado para
conversar com ele no começo ao fim
acabam de contando por que
aguardando boy ele disse temos um quadro
no qual é porque eu tenho três irmãos
menores não puderam vir até que hoje eu
tô pagando melhor pra eles eles nunca
morre
à sua volta não foi legal do passado
porque é propagada a gente faz com que
tem como pode e como não conta mais com
a família e os amigos principalmente nas
redes sociais
então essas redes sociais o que eu fiz
ali agente repassou o amigo vai passando
vai realizando no facebook
uma delas é uma ideia original de tempo
ou o colégio 12 foram na casa de todo
mundo
a morte mais recente álbum sem conter o
problema de saúde sustentável
há um projeto em parceria com cristiano
um irmãozão mil
são paulo o instituto de saúde na
formação e na própria polícia e
determinada na noite deste ano fez a
tentativa dele de mim e ele entrou em um
bar em são paulo
o colocou em uma área onde o pessoal
trabalhando
ele caiu ali um sonho extremamente
consciente
o pessoal trabalhando para o negócio de
tecnologias sustentáveis em casa mas
assim como está fazendo aqui é um dos
responsáveis por saúde trabalho e era
uma verdade incontestável falando coisas
pessoas e eu lembrei de pessoas naquela
região porque em contato com essas
pessoas conservadoras para sempre essas
pessoas ele entrou em contato com dois
conseguiu falar com um valor nunca teve
um sequência de uma cultura sem licença
a última dar uma resposta ao contrato
depois disso ele começou o trabalho dela
saindo do quarto ano da ordem por ano na
amazônia paraíso onde trabalha com saúde
sustentável através das práticas
integrativas e complementares que são
práticas de saúde milenares extremamente
de casa de um custo baixíssimo a bahia e
pessoal
hoje além de fazer os atendimentos de
atendimentos capacitações e da região
no mesmo ano encontrei ela é uma mulher
de cadeira de rodas sem telas uma
expressão facial sem falar no segundo
ano já estava vencendo no ano passado
por lá sozinha
já tinha expressão facial já sorria está
começando a mexer um pouco as pernas
mais difícil
ela estava atrás eu não tenho pai
isso aqui de graça se faz parte do
produto que vocês acreditam eles olharam
alguns de vocês já sabem que já
encontraram os produtos
ele encontrou a cabeça de fumar correndo
pra vocês qualidade obtendo pra vocês
voluntariado
espero que vocês também contém essa
idéia para ajudar os alunos gols pra
mudar principalmente no de vocês mundo
solo do mundo